all right so I log on to shadi calm how
does the magic work how does it start
oh not to a typical I think you know
just like in the West you have match and
as I said II harmony and so on these
other platforms you create a profile our
profiles are a little more elaborate and
you know simply putting your age and
your name I'd say about a third of the
time the profiles that are put on
shaadi.com I put up by family members
people find life partners as you said do
people find love so if you think of
marriage from a Hindu lens or Indian
lens it is not a question of if right it
is a question of when in the West you
marry when you bump into somebody you
hopefully have a chemical reaction and
you know you say I love you and if vagus
is close by it happens sooner than you'd
like it to but in India it is a stage of
life we go through childhood we go
through adolescence and then we go
through what is called a domestic stage
of life before you retire and typically
that's between the ages of your early
20s to early 30s and that's the time
that our sort of traditions prescribed
finding a life partner because that is
the most optimal time for you to run a
domestic household and have you know
give but two children and raise a family
and so the love that we look at when we
think about love in India is a love that
grows over a long time it's not
necessary a chemical reaction where you
fall in love you find love out of
respect for each other over time and so
it comes back to that question you
started with which is what is love
falling in love versus maybe growing
growing love yes